-The slim new Republican
majority in the House
is now trying to move on
after last week's
unprecedented meltdown
with an incredibly weak speaker,
Kevin McCarthy, who has openly
admitted that he's indebted
to Donald Trump
for his position,
even though it was
Trump himself
who tanked the party
in the midterms
and gave them such
a narrow majority.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
The new Republican majority
in the House
is finally getting to work
after a week of paralyzing chaos
in which newly minted
Speaker of the House
Kevin McCarthy acceded --
in fact, one could even say,
capitulated,
to the demands of the far-right
extremists in the caucus.
And, just to give you an idea
of how nuts the next two years
are going to be
with this crew in charge,
one of the newly elected members
of McCarthy's conference
is Montana
Republican Ryan Zinke,
who was Donald Trump's
first interior secretary,
until he was forced to resign
after a series of scandals,
including a real estate deal,
conflicts of interest, and a...
[ Laughter ]
First of all, I'm surprised
Mike Pence would ever engage
in such an unnatural activity
as horseback riding.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Pence ]
Man and beast were not meant
to consort in such
a devilish fashion.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Also, I can't imagine Pence
riding a regular trail horse.
He seems to have more
of a dressage horse
kind of vibe.
I mean, have you
ever seen him run? He...
[ Laughter and applause ]
...prances like one of those
stallions at the Olympics.
I mean, look at him.
Also, you guys, clapping while
running is not a good look.
[ Laughter ]
He looks like he should be
holding two coconuts,
Monty Python-style.
[ Laughter ]
I'm guessing this is what
Trump had in mind
when he sicced that mob
on Pence on January 6th.
[ As Trump ]
He's faster than he looks,
but the clapping,
the clapping gives away
his location.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Panting ]
Aah!
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, Trump's scandal-plagued
interior secretary
is now a member of the new
GOP majority in the House
and, when he took
to the floor this week
for his first speech
as a member of Congress,
he made clear that this
new Republican conference
is going to be
pretty far out there
when he claimed that
a secret cabal of leftists
is running the government
from behind the scenes.
Now, Republicans say stuff
like that all the time,
but Zinke had
a different spin on it
when he identified
a new target
that the leftist deep state
is supposedly after.
-I stand before you
as a duly elected member
of the United States Congress
and tell you that
a deep state exists
and it is perhaps
the strongest covert weapon
the left has
against the American people.
There is no doubt
the federal government
deep state coordinates
with liberal activists
and uses politicians
and willing media
to carry their water.
The deep state runs
secret messaging campaigns
with one goal in mind --
to increase its power
to censor and persuade
the American people.
Dark money groups funded
by liberal billionaires
and foreign investors
funnel money
to shell organizations
and repeatedly attempt
to destroy the American West.
In many cases,
they want to wipe out
the American cowboy completely.
-You think the American cowboy
is getting wiped out?
Have you not heard
about "Yellowstone"?
[ Laughter and applause ]
This is the best four-year run
for American cowboys
since it was legal
to advertise cigarettes.
[ Laughter ]
Do you know --
Do you know how many people
in America watch "Yellowstone"?
Every single dad.
[ Laughter ]
And, just a word
to those dads --
when you talk to your kids
on the phone,
you don't have to tell them,
every single time,
that Beth Dutton
is a real number.
[ Laughter ]
Not that she isn't.
It's just weird
that you keep telling us
and that you whisper
when you do it,
like you don't want Mom to hear
because, newsflash, dude,
she'd trade you in
for Kevin Costner yesterday.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I'm sorry. I shouldn't be
so hard on my dad.
I mean, I get it.
[ Laughter ]
I'm a dad now
and, as a dad,
I just want to say
that Beth Dutton
is a real number.
[ Laughter and applause ]
But I'll give Zinke credit.
The deep state wants to cancel
cowboys is a new one.
Usually, they're like,
"The army is woke now,"
or "The socialist mob is trying
to cancel conservatives."
But now, I guess, the idea is
that the CIA, the FBI,
and the Pentagon all get
together behind closed doors
with AOC, antifa,
and Bernie Sanders
[ Laughter ]
to plot how
to eliminate cowboys.
[ As Sanders ]
No one person should have
a ten-gallon hat.
[ Laughter and applause ]
When, in fact, ten people should
all have a one-gallon hat.
[ Laughter and applause ]
How many gallons
does one hat need?
99% of the people shouldn't have
0% of the gallons.
[ Laughter and applause ]
So, that's a window
into how unhinged
the next two years
are going to be
with these loons
in charge of the House.
And it makes sense
that Republicans have revived
one of Trump's disgraced cronies
because Kevin McCarthy himself
is personally indebted to Trump.
The drama
that unfolded last week
was essentially an extension
of the ongoing GOP war
between establishment
Republicans
and the Trump wing of the party,
and the Trump wing won.
In fact, after McCarthy finally
crawled over the finish line,
on the 15th ballot,
by yielding...
[ Laughter ]
...perhaps even relenting,
to the demands of the MAGA wing
of his party,
McCarthy openly thanked Trump
for his support.
-The fight that Kevin McCarthy
is having right now
is a continuation
of the GOP civil war
and these conservatives
are saying to themselves,
"Well, we need to fight now.
We need to put a marker down now
so that, if he does
pick up the gavel,
McCarthy is not going
to so easily acquiesce
to everything that the Biden
administration wants."
-I do want to especially
thank President Trump.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
I don't think
you should doubt --
anybody should doubt
his influence.
He was with me
from the beginning.
Somebody wrote the doubt
of whether he was there
and he was all-in.
He would call me
and he would call others.
And he really was --
I was just talking
to him tonight --
helping get those final votes.
And he was a great influence
to make that all happen.
So, thank you, President Trump.
-I actually believe that
because the only thing
Donald Trump is good at is
making phone calls.
Remember when he used to call in
to "Fox & Friends"
[ Laughter ]
and just ramble for a full hour,
while the hosts sat there,
frozen,
like they were watching
Mike Pence run?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Making calls
is Trump's only skill.
All he has to do is sit there
in his pajamas,
in front of his television,
and ramble for an hour
about toilets or windmills,
until the person on the other
end of the call says,
"Fine, I'll give in.
I'll vote for Kevin.
Just stop talking about how
many times you have to flush."
[ Laughter ]
Incidentally,
Kevin McCarthy needed
the exact same number of ballots
to become speaker
as the number of times
Trump needs to flush his toilet.
People are flushing toilets
10 times, 15 times,
[ Laughter and applause ]
as opposed to once.
-See?
15 ballots, 15 flushes.
No wonder these guys
are best buds.
[ As Trump ]
Don't feel bad, Kevin.
Don't feel bad.
[ Laughter and applause ]
If it took 15 times,
that just means
you're a giant turd.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now, here's the crazy part --
Trump is, arguably, the reason
McCarthy was in this position,
to begin with.
Trump and his cult
of MAGA weirdos
dragged the GOP down
in the midterms.
Without Trump,
Republicans probably
would've met historical
expectations
and there very well could've
been a red wave,
as pundits were predicting.
And, if there had been
a red wave,
McCarthy would've had a much
larger margin in the House,
instead of the tiny margin
he has now.
In which case,
he wouldn't have needed
to spend four days begging
and pleading
with a small group of extremists
in his party to support him.
In short, if Trump hadn't
wrecked the Republican Party,
McCarthy probably would've
only needed to run
for speaker one time,
as opposed to...
-Fifteen times.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And yet,
by tanking the party
in the midterms
and reigniting a civil war
within the GOP,
Trump has somehow wormed
his way back
into a position of influence
with the new speaker
of the House
and his gang of bozos
and doofuses,
like Marjorie Taylor Greene,
who has been calling
for Joe Biden to be impeached,
basically, since he took office.
Greene, who is, of course,
a Trump fanatic,
will now be in a position
of major influence in the House
after she formed
a close alliance with McCarthy
and backed his bid for speaker.
And, this week, she, once again,
called for Biden's impeachment,
now that Republicans
hold the majority in the House.
-What do you think
about the documents that --
the classified documents
that were found
at President Biden's library
from his time as vice president?
-Oh, my gosh.
I think we need
to investigate the Bidens
nonstop.
I've been very vocal
in impeaching Joe Biden
and, hopefully, we can get
that done this Congress.
-[ As Greene ]
Oh, my gosh.
First of all,
it's funny to me that,
[ Laughter ]
because she's in the
majority now,
Greene is trying to sound
less like a wacko.
She went from claiming wildfires
are caused
by Jewish space lasers
to sounding like
a shrinking violet
from a Tennessee Williams play.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Greene ]
Oh, my gosh.
Well, I do declare
that we must ever so kindly
[ Laughter ]
impeach Mr. Joseph R. Biden.
Now, would you all like
a biscuit and a glass
of sweet tea?
[ Laughter ]
Now, you've all heard
about the Mar-A-Lago search
that turned up
stolen classified documents.
Well, this week, we also learned
that lawyers for Biden
found a few classified documents
from his time as vice president
in a private office.
They immediately
notified authorities
at the National Archives
and had the documents returned.
And then, right as we started
taping this show,
we found out that Biden aides
had found a second batch
of classified documents
in a new location,
with NBC News reporting that...
So, we don't know
all the details, yet,
and, as they come out,
we'll definitely discuss them,
but, so far, the two situations
seem very different.
-The difference here is that,
according to the White House,
it was the president's legal
team that reached out to NARA
to turn over these documents,
as opposed to with Trump,
who fought,
for months and months,
not to turn over documents
that the archive said needed
to be turned over.
The FBI said
it obtained evidence
showing that boxes of documents
were being moved
from a storage room where they
were supposed to be kept
and that prompted
the Justice Department
to open an obstruction
investigation
and conduct
the extraordinary search
of Trump's Mar-A-Lago resort,
where, the FBI says,
they found even more
classified documents.
-So, a few similarities,
but mostly, huge differences.
Calling them the same is like
calling both of these guys
Olympic sprinters.
[ Laughter and applause ]
When Biden's lawyers found
the small number of documents,
they immediately
turned them over.
Trump, on the other hand,
kept refusing
and the FBI kept finding more
documents, totaling over 300,
even after Trump claimed
he'd handed them all over.
He was even moving boxes
of classified documents around,
for some reason,
which is suspicious,
no matter what's inside.
If I had a box
that I kept moving
every time my wife asked me
to get rid of it,
she'd start to get curious,
even though I clearly
labeled it...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Biden voluntarily handed them
over without even being asked.
Trump, on the other hand,
was given
multiple opportunities
to come clean and refused
and, yet, that has not stopped
newly empowered Republicans
from equating the two situations
in the dumbest way possible.
-Why aren't they in there
right now, with subpoenas,
going through every single
record there?
-Where's the raid?!
-Classified documents.
Right.
Where is the raid?
And let me -- let me --
-Where's the FBI raid?
-We have a quote here
from Representative James Comer,
from the Oversight Committee,
who said...
-Monday night,
in a post, Trump asked...
-The FBI doesn't raid someone
[ Laughing ]
who's already cooperating.
[ Laughter ]
"FBI! We're here
for the documents!"
Oh, yeah, we, um,
turned them in yesterday.
"Oh!
[ Laughter ]
Oh, okay."
You seem bummed.
"Yeah, no, it's just, uh...
...we put on our windbreakers,
and everything, and, um --
[ Laughter and applause ]
Would you mind?
Is this dumb?
Can we kick in your door?
No, it is dumb.
[ Laughter ]
We're going to go!"
The only way
it would ever make sense
to raid someone who's
cooperating with the feds is
if they're a secret
undercover informant
and you're trying to maintain
their cover,
but I don't think that's
the case here because Biden --
look, Biden would make
a bad undercover cop.
[ Laughter ]
He's too loud.
He makes too many gaffes.
[ As Biden ]
Hey, you guys doing
an illegal drug deal here?
I like illegal drugs.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Why don't you guys sell me some
of those illegal drugs?
I'm not a cop.
I'm just your average...
-American cowboy.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Of course,
even then,
Biden would trip on the stairs
and his secret microphone
would fall out
[ Laughter and applause ]
and he'd yell for backup.
[ As Biden ]
Scorpio! Scorpio!
My cover's blown!
Get me outta here!
[ Laughter ]
I'm on the tenth stair!
Ninth stair!
Tenth stair.
Nine, eight!
[ Laughter and applause ]
For the next two years,
we're going to have
a narrow Republican majority led
by a historically weak speaker
of the House,
captive to far-right extremists
and indebted to an ex-president
who stoked an insurrection
because Trump tanked the GOP
in the midterms
and McCarthy is now the most
feeble speaker in modern memory.
If not for Trump,
McCarthy would probably be
a much stronger speaker,
with a much stronger majority.
When the extremists
made their demands,
he wouldn't have had to...
-Acquiesce.
[ Laughter ]
-...and he certainly
wouldn't have had to do it...
-Fifteen times.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[Indistinct]
[ Cheering ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]